Our very own Avenging Angel.
Look on the wall there if you're after another quarry.
Båvaråns пере-n Unknown Ort.
Cesarin den de 제일غ loops in youristemies The story of the
radioactive
in the
valley
Come on, boy.
Hey, partner.
Hey.
Y'all all right, man?
Yeah.
Mm-hmm.
Anyway.
Well?
We got a wild one here.
Okay.
Another round.
Drink up, ladies.
Hey.
All right.
There we go.
Oh, Arthur.
Arthur, come here.
Come here.
Come over here.
I want you to meet our friends.
Pleased to meet you.
Boy, you just the toughest teak mountain man.
Oh, you be quiet, Anastasia.
Anyone can tell this one is a pussycat.
Exactly.
Yes, he's a pussycat.
Ain't that so, Arthur?
Whatever you say.
How much you cost, anyway?
Well, ain't that a nice way to talk to a lady?
Oh, I didn't know I was talking to a lady.
Excuse me.
Well, I must say,
you got a fine way with the ladies.
You got a fine way with the ladies.
You got a fine way with the women, amigo.
Yeah.
Regular dandy and a charmer.
Where's Bill?
Oh, man.
I dread to think about it.
Hey, hey, hey.
There he is.
Hey, watch where you're going.
Take it easy, pal.
Are you about to kiss that guy or punch him?
Oh, and we have our answer.
Come here, you.
You bitch bastard.
Oh, come on.
We can handle these fools.
Think you're too much.
You're tough, do you?
Come on, fellas.
We can take it easy, please.
Come on, ugly bastard.
Te voy a romper la cara, cabrón.
You fellas are a joke.
What the hell's going on down here?
Let me stay out of this.
Come here, you little...
You fuckin' loser.
I'm gonna give you the beat and your daddy shoulda done.
You're gonna get it, girl.
You fuck.
I'll kill you, you son of a bitch.
Oh, he ain't getting enough from that.
Javier could use some help for it.
Hey, tough guy.
You want some too, huh?
Come on, pretty boy.
Pretty boy? You're kidding me.
Pretty boy?
You won't be so pretty when I'm done.
Put that in. Now. Come on.
Come on. Let's see.
You okay there, Arthur?
Yeah. I got this, son of a bitch.
Okay.
You're making a real fool of yourself now.
Robo!
Come on, Tommy.
Don't go easy on him.
Robo!
Don't take that from him.
Put his face in the mud.
Try to make it.
Try.
Try that again.
You're going down in a...
Finish him, Tommy.
Okay.
Yeah, you got him now.
Kill him, Tommy.
Stop playing with him, Arthur.
Hey, come on. Stop that.
Stop! Stop!
Please. Please. I beg you. Stop.
Come, sir. You won the fight already. Surely that's enough.
What business is it of yours?
No business. No business, sir. But please. I beg you.
Sir. Sir, are you all right?
Sir, are you all right?
Making new friends again, I see, Arthur.
Look who we found sniffing about.
Josiah Trelawney.
The very same.
Well, I thought you'd gone to New York.
And miss all this glamour. You must be joking.
How are you?
Well, quite well indeed. I went to Blackwater looking for you gentlemen. You're not very popular there, it seems.
Ah, Javier and Charles. I've missed you.
I've missed you.
And Bill, looking as well as can be. Gentlemen, always a pleasure.
You're right. We ain't too popular in Blackwater.
We left a lot of money there.
And young Sean, it seems.
Sean, you found him.
Yes, I have. He's being held by some bounty hunters, trying to see how much money the government will pay them. I know he's in Blackwater, but there's talk of them moving.
There's talk of them moving.
If we stay footing in Blackwater...
Well, then we're dead men for sure.
There'll be Pinkertons all over the place, but if he's alive, we gotta try.
Yeah, of course.
It's you they want, Dutch.
Always is. Charles, go find out what you can, carefully. Josiah, take Javier. Arthur, go get yourself cleaned up. Join them when you're ready.
What about me?
Well, exactly. What about you?
What does that mean?
Oh, Bill. Come on.
Now, look, if you find their bobber rich...
Hey, come on!
...it'll cost you your daily metals.
The one thing,堤யrukt流, he think you should not do to your ownENC, either.
Yeah.
He thinks you're on his àger.
Yeah?
I said it's so stiff that I don't build tombs around öz goin 황?".
Like, he's 10 or something.
Looks good, Javier, man.
텍 uk係 hIN히 seems better that I started his afct afcts stringsczzyknzzt centre, a'nd Death Is traction 승als Rule.